Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This work is about building a robot that works
even when being damaged, and you will see
that the results are just unreal.
There are many important applications for
such a robot where sending out humans may
be too risky, such as putting out forest fires,
finding earthquake survivors under rubble,
or shutting down a malfunctioning nuclear
plant.
Since these are all dangerous use cases, it
is a requirement that such a robot works even
when damaged.
The key idea to accomplish this is that we
allow the robot to perform tasks such as walking
not only in one, optimal way, but to explore
and build a map of many alternative motions
relying on different body parts.
Some of these limping motions are clearly
not optimal, but, whenever damage happens
to the robot, it will immediately be able
to choose at least one alternative way to
move around, even with broken or missing legs.
After building the map, it can be used as
additional knowledge to lean on when the damage
occurs, and the robot doesn't have to re-learn
everything from scratch.
This is great, especially given that damage
usually happens in the presence of danger,
and in these cases, reacting quickly can be
a matter of life and death.
However, creating such a map takes a ton of
trial and error, potentially more than what
we can realistically get the robot to perform.
And now comes my favorite part, which is,
starting a project in a computer simulation,
and then, in the next step, deploying the
trained AI to a real robot.
This previously mentioned map of movements
contains over 13,000 different kinds of gaits,
and since we are in a simulation, it can be
computed efficiently and conveniently.
In software, we can also simulate all kinds
of damage for free without dismembering our
real robot.
And since no simulation is perfect, after
this step, the AI is deployed to the real
robot that evaluates and adjusts to the differences.
By the way, this is the same robot that surprised
us in the previous episode when it showed
that it can walk around just fine without
any foot contact with the ground by jumping
on its back and using its elbows.
I can only imagine how much work this project
took, and the results speak for themselves.
It is also very easy to see the immediate
utility of such a project.
Bravo.
I also recommend looking at the press materials.
For instance, in the frequently asked questions,
many common misunderstandings are addressed.
For instance, it is noted that the robot doesn't
understand the kind of damage that occurred,
and doesn't repair itself in the strict sense
but it tries to find alternative ways to function.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!